CBS News has confirmed that a six
migrant child is known to have died
after crossing into the u.s. the Health
and Human Services Department said
yesterday that the little ten-year-old
girl died eight months ago
Omar Villafranca is at the border patrol
processing center in McAllen Texas was
more on this story Omar good morning to
you good morning many children are
brought to this processing center but
just to be clear the little girl who
died in September did not die here but
the head of the Hispanic Congressional
Caucus is accusing the Trump
administration of trying to cover up her
death the Department of Health and Human
Services tells CBS News that in March
2018 a ten year old girl entered the
care of the office of refugee
resettlement in San Antonio they say she
had a history of congenital heart
defects and following a surgical
procedure became comatose then in
September at a hospital near family in
Nebraska she died due to fever and
respiratory distress the revelation
comes just days after Carlos Hernandez
died while in Border Patrol custody the
16 year old from Guatemala was diagnosed
with the flu at the Maine border patrol
processing facility in McAllen intake of
migrants at that facility was
temporarily suspended Tuesday after 32
people were diagnosed with the flu we
continue to face tragedies at the border
particularly with regard to the safety
of children on Capitol Hill Wednesday
Acting Secretary of Homeland Security
Kevin McAlinden was confronted by
Illinois Democrat Loren Underwood about
the situation at the border at this
point with five kids that have died
5,000 separated from their families I
feel like and the evidence is really
clear that this is intentional it's
intentional it's a policy choice being
made on purpose by this administration
and it's cruel and inhumane that's an
appalling accusation and our men and
women fight hard to protect people in
our custody every single day this will
not be the last death there are going to
be more Catherine Hampton works for the
advocacy group physicians for Human
Rights she says these deaths are an
inevitable consequence of a system that
detains thousands of migrant children
the entire medical community have been
warning that this is going to happen
what I'm most terrified of in this
moment is
we're gonna become so desensitized but
these deaths don't mean anything anymore
here at the Macallan processing center
the Border Patrol told us to stop the
spread of the flu they sanitized the
building they did more medical
assessments and they also gave medical
care where it was needed and after all
that normal operations resumed yesterday
afternoon
Tony Omar just more great reporting from
you and your team down there I guess the
big question now is why are we only
hearing today about that child's death
if it happened all the way back in
September interesting note because
government agencies like HHS or Orr
don't have to publicly report a migrant
child's death they just have to report
it internally into child welfare groups
and that may be one of the reasons why
we're just hearing about it now yeah and
I certainly hope it's the last one Omar
thank you very much